this relationship is the first time
you've actually loved myself and been
open to loving and being loved by
someone else yeah yeah Adele is happy
and living her
boyfriend Rich Paul have put their love
on display showing the world some of
their sweetest moments together
the love birds first sparked dating
rumors when they were spotted courtside
at the NBA finals in July of 2021 and
just two months later the couple went
Instagram official with Adele posting
this sweet snap
[Music]
in October the pair made another
Courtside appearance at the NBA season
opener check out the pair getting fired
up for the game Adele even opened up to
Vogue about the romance for their
November issue rich just incredibly
arrived I don't feel anxious or nervous
or frazzled it's quite the opposite it's
wild
[Music]
and later that month Adele revealed to
Oprah what she loves about rich this is
hilarious he's also hilarious oh he's so
funny okay no he's hilarious yeah and
very smart you know he's very very smart
it's quite quite incredible watching him
do what he does this relationship is the
first time you've actually loved myself
and been open to loving and being loved
by someone else yeah it's just timing
but it'd be interesting to see what my
reaction is like in general to anything
that hurts me now that I feel so secure
in myself and I'm talking outside of
romance as well I'm just wearing any
scenario then in February of last year
Adele shocked fans when she attended the
Brit Awards wearing a diamond ring on
that finger and her reaction was
priceless she played koi on The Graham
Norton Show I thought left hand didn't
move as much as normal it seemed heavier
thank you
is there as if I would ever tell anyone
if I was or wasn't just
Justice later a Dallin Rich responded
holding hands Courtside and in May she
posted these sweet photos on Instagram
of the two watching a game and sharing a
kiss writing in the caption time flies
[Music]
something real something that feels true
Adele even opened up about wanting a
potential family with Rich sharing with
L in August quote I've never been in
love like this I definitely want more
kids
love you
love you free
and in her happy hour with Adele live
stream she doesn't hold back making
special time for Rich and stuff like
that and um I mean the season just
started and believe me I'm actually a
really big basketball fan thank God
yeah the Superstar wrapped up 2022 with
a sweet
sweet for Rich during her Vegas
cheers to more special moments for the
couple in the new year
foreign